Marjorie Taylor green yes the radical
and repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene is reportedly
being considered to be Donald Trump's
running mate in 2024.
for months reports Business Insider
Trump has repeatedly discussed choosing
Marjorie Taylor Greene as his 2024
running mate
um this is per Robert Draper of the New
York Times magazine As Told to uh The
Daily Beast Trump is considering green
this won't come as a surprise to you
because of her unflagging loyalty to him
speaking on this week's episode of The
Daily beasts the new abnormal podcast
Draper claimed the discussions have been
ongoing for months it's been discussed
repeatedly now to be fair I mean how
many of these conversations has Trump
had with other people
what is Trump concerned about most of
all in a VP after the Mike Pence
experience loyalty loyalty Trump needs
someone who will quote fight for him to
overturn a presidential election he has
every reason to expect that green would
be by his side and would be his
proximate Warrior earlier this week
green told Draper she's discussed with
Trump the possibility of serving as his
running mate she said she would be
honored to serve but the GOP
establishment would not want it so
listen
she's completely out of her mind crazy
she is
um
loyal is not even the right word but yes
she's unendingly loyal to Trump in the
sense of following whatever disastrous
instinct or talking point Trump is
distracted by that week as the latest
shiny object I don't know on the one
hand why Trump thinks it would help him
to have Marjorie Taylor green and as his
running mate but in all seriousness
let's not write it off and what I mean
by that is remember that Trump won the
Republican primary of 2016.
Trump then won the presidential election
you could come to me with tears in your
eyes and say Sir Trump is considering
Jeffrey Dahmer where he's still alive as
VP and I'd say that's insane
and he still might win the most
depressing era in a long time for sure
and I don't think green necessarily
hurts Trump now on the other hand I
don't know that she necessarily helps
and what I mean by that is like in all
seriousness
does Marjorie Taylor green bring any new
voters to Donald Trump
I don't know that she does if you are in
the Romney wing of the Republican party
or the Liz Cheney wing of the Republican
party and you don't like Democrats but
you're just not sold on Trump
if Trump picks Romney maybe you go with
the Trump Romney ticket now that's not
being considered I'm just saying maybe
that gets you to go over to the Trump
side
but if you're already in kind of like
the Romney kinzinger Liz Cheney wing of
the Republican Party does Trump picking
Marjorie Taylor green get you over to
trump it doesn't seem like it and so on
the one hand I don't think because of
how delusional and dangerous and
dystopian this Republican party and
electorate is I don't know that there's
anyone that would really hurt Trump
the thing about Marjorie Taylor green is
I don't think she helps Trump find new
voters which is what he needs to do if
he hopes to defeat Joe Biden or whoever
it is on the Democratic side in November
of 24
because he needs to find some new voters
relative to 2020. I don't know that
Marjorie Taylor green helps him do that
but I want to hear from you let me know